je vous la fais courte
je m'appelle star Lord
j'ai fondé les gardiens
j'ai rencontré une fille je suis tombé
amoureux
cette fille est morte et puis elle est
revenue
[Applaudissements]
sauf qu'elle est devenue tarée comment
tu as oublié quelques infos importantes
mais
tu as résumé l'essentiel
ma mission sacrée
c'est de créer la société parfaite
c'est pas qu'il aimait la perfection
c'est plutôt qu'il détestait les choses
telles qu'elles sont
avec vous sachiez tout ce que je suis
honoré de me battre à côté de mes amis
incinérer
on a toujours été en quête d'une famille
jusqu'à ce qu'on se rencontre
vous êtes prêts
pour une dernière virée
tous ensemble
à travers l'infinité
de ce merveilleux ciel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais pas trop de qui tu étais
amoureux mais ça ressemble plus à elle
quoi
j'avais jamais remarqué que tu avais de
beaux yeux noirs ils ont été remplacés
par mon père quand il me torturait je
trouve qu'il les a bien choisis